Bree sets me up on a date with Peter
from The Bachelorette yes Nikki Bella is
back in the dating game but she says it
hasn't exactly been a smooth ride that
was like my first like just like first
date and what over six or seven years
yeah it was so awkward
you were very awkward I saw when I got
drunk the brunette beauty and her twin
sister Bree were guests on Tuesdays busy
tonight
Nikki candidly addressed what it's like
to date and film a reality series at the
same time I think that's what
embarrassed me a lot is you're having
this first day and I look to my left and
it's like two camera crews and I'm like
oh my god this is so weird like I didn't
even really want to flirt because it
just was so awkward when we watched it
back I got so bright with that said it
didn't come as much of a surprise when
Nikki said she has no interest in being
the Bachelorette how now I don't know
how they do that and they kissed like
everyone a 35 year old pro wrestler has
been an open book on total Bella's since
calling off her engagement from John
Cena last summer but I just can't
imagine my life without you John I just
can't imagine not getting married and
spending the rest of her life to get
there but in September Nikki told ET
she's found joy in this next chapter of
her life I feel like if I'm at that age
where I'm discovering who I really am
and what do I want out of life and just
like independence
and I'm enjoying it mocking allies it's
scary and you have these moments of like
what am i doing and you have fear but I
just I kind of am liking the challenge
and that beer because it's just sports
tuna be out of my comfort zone nikki is
definitely out of her comfort zone as
she gets back in the dating pool
[Music]
but at the end of the day Nikki says
she's simply focused on one goal the
happiness like just fully being happy
and so that's what I really want
[Music]